>>> IN AN INTERVIEW YOU'LL S
FIRST "OUTFRONT,A NEW JERSEY
VETERAN IS SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
EMBATTLED REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
GEORGE SANTOS, CLAIMING THE
CONGRESSMAN PROMISED TO HELP HIS
SERVICE DOG GET LIFE-SAVING
SURGERY IN 2016.
BUT AFTER ABOUT $3,000 OF
DONATIONS POURED IN, THE NAVY
VETERAN SAYS SANTOS STOPPED
REPLYING TO HIS CALLS, TO HIS
TEXTS.
THE VETERAN NEVER SAW A DIME.
HIS DOG PASSED AWAY MONTHS
LATER.
AND THE FUNDRAISER WAS SET UP
UNDER A CHARITY GROUP THAT
SANTOS ACTUALLY MENTIONED ON HIS
CAMPAIGN WEBSITE.
YOU SEE IT HERE.
IN A PARAGRAPH THAT HAS SINCE
BEEN DELETED.
IT CLAIMED THAT HE RESCUED 2,400
DOGS AND 280 CATS.
SANTOS ALSO TOUTED THE CHARITY
IN THIS INTERVIEW.
>> I MEAN, WE HAD A GREAT
ORGANIZATION.
WE WERE ABLE TO SAVE ANIMALS,
DOGS, CATS, HORSES.
AT ONE POINT I STUCK EIGHT BABY
JUMPING GOATS IN MY CAR.
>> THERE IS NO RECORD OF THIS
GROUP IN THE IRS DATABASE.
AND THE WEBSITE GoFundMe WHERE
THIS FUNDRAISER WAS POSTED SAID
THAT THE ORGANIZER FAILED TO
RESPOND TO ALL THEIR INQUIRIES
ABOUT WHERE THE FUNDS WENT,
NEVER GAVE ANY PROOF OF ANYTHING
AND SO THEY BANNED SANTOS'
ACCOUNT.
THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
CONTINUES TO STAND BY SANTOS
TONIGHT PUTTING HIM ON TWO
COMMITTEES JUST THIS WEEK.
"OUTFRONT" NOW, THE NAVY VETERAN
WHO WAS MAKING THE CLAIMS ABOUT
SANTOS, AND THE FOUNDER OF THE
NEW JERSEY VETERANS NETWORK WHO
TRIED TO INTERVENE AND GET THE
MONEY FROM SANTOS.
SO, LOOK, I'M SO GLAD TO SPEAK
TO BOTH OF YOU.
AND, RICH, YOU SERVED IN THE
U.S. NAVY.
I KNOW YOUR SERVICE DOG SAPPHIRE
WAS YOUR SAVIOR AND SO IMPORTANT
IN YOUR LIFE.
SHE'S HERE.
YOU WANTED TO BRING HER.
>> I HAD TO BRING HER, YEAH.
IT'S MY BABY RIGHT THERE.
IT'S ALL I HAVE LEFT OF HER.
>> AND, YOU KNOW, WHEN GEORGE
SANTOS WHO AT THE TIME I GUESS
YOU KNEW HIM, SHE WAS GOING TO
HELP YOU SAVE HER FROM CANCER.
>> HE WAS GOING TO USE HIS
CHARITY, HIS 501K, PETS OF
FRIENDS UNITED TO RAISE FUNDS
OVER GoFundMe.
HE SAID HE WAS VERY RESPECTED,
HE WAS VERY -- HE HAD HIS
FEELERS OUT.
AND WITH HIS CHARITY, IT WOULD
HELP ME VERY MUCH TO GET THE
MONEY IN A SOONER AMOUNT OF TIME
THAN LATER.
>> YOU WERE HOMELESS AT THE
TIME.
>> I HAD BROKEN AN ANKLE REALLY
BAD, COULDN'T WORK FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF AND I COULDN'T PAY MY
RENT AND WAS LIVING IN A TENT ON
THE SIDE OF A HIGHWAY WITH MY
DOG.
SHE HAD ALREADY HAD THAT GROWTH
GROWING.
I FINALLY DECIDED TO TAKE HER TO
THE VET TO SEE WHAT THEY COULD
DO.
AND THEY GAVE ME A $3,000 QUOTE
TO REMOVE IT.
I WAS HOMELESS.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY MEANS TO PAY
FOR THAT AT ALL.
SO ONE OF THE VET TECHS IN THE
PLACE SAID I KNOW THIS GUY, HE
RUNS A CHARITY, AND HE SAVES A
LOT OF ANIMALS.
SHE WAS, LIKE, DO YOU WANT ME TO
HOOK YOU UP WITH HIM?
SO SHE TOOK PICTURES OF ME AND
SAPPHIRE.
SHE SENT THEM TO HIM.
AND THE GoFundMe STARTED.
IT WAS UP AND RUNNING.
I PUT IT ON MY FACEBOOK PAGE.
MY FRIENDS AND FAMILY DONATED TO
IT, THEY SHARED IT.
I HAD A LOT OF MY NAVY BUDDIES
THAT I HADN'T HEARD FROM IN
YEARS GIVE ME HUNDREDS TOWARDS
IT.
THERE WERE SOME OTHER DONORS
THAT I DIDN'T EVER RECOGNIZE
THEIR NAMES OR ANYTHING.
THEY MIGHT'VE BEEN FRIENDS OF
FRIENDS, FOR ALL I KNOW.
SO WE RAISED $3,000 IN TWO
MONTHS, MAYBE THREE MONTHS.
IT WAS SIX YEARS AGO.
AND AS SOON AS THE MONEY CAME, I
WAS, LIKE, GREAT.
>> YOU COULD SAVE YOUR DOG.
>> MR. SANTOS DECIDED THAT HE
DID NOT WANT ME TO USE MY LOCAL
BET.
HE WANTED ME TO USE HIS IN LONG
ISLAND OR QUEENS.
I DON'T REMEMBER WHICH BOROUGH
OR TOWN IT WAS IN.
AND THAT WAS THE ONLY WAY HE WAS
GOING TO GET IT HAPPEN.
SO WE TOOK THE DOG TO THE VET,
AND THE VET SAID, WELL, WE
BELIEVE THIS IS TWO VASCULAR,
IT'S INOPERABLE, BUT WE'D LIKE
TO GO AND HAVE HER -- HAVE AN
ULTRASOUND SO WE CAN SEE IF WE
CAN DO ANYTHING WITH IT.
I DON'T DRIVE, I WAS HOMELESS,
AND I PAID A RIDE.
I PAID A FRIEND TO BRING ME UP
THERE.
>> TO HIS VET?
>> TO HIS VET.
I PAID THE TOLLS, THE GAS,
LUNCHES.
AND HE WAS SUPPOSED TO PAY ME
BACK FOR THAT.
I EVEN WAS DUMB ENOUGH TO GIVE
HIM MY BANK ACCOUNT AND MY
ROUTING NUMBER BECAUSE HE SAID
HE WAS GOING TO PUT THE MONEY
RIGHT INTO MY ACCOUNT.
NEVER HAPPENED.
THAT WAS WHEN I STARTED SMELLING
SOMETHING FISHY.
>> AND SO AT THIS POINT,
MICHAEL, YOU GET INVOLVED TO TRY
TO HELP HIM GET THE MONEY.
YOU HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
SANTOS.
AGAIN, AT THIS TIME YOU KNEW HIM
AS ANTHONY.
WHAT WERE THOSE LIKE?
>> MY GOAL WAS JUST TO SPEAK TO
ANOTHER CHARITY.
THE LAST THING THAT CROSSED MY
MIND WAS THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE
A PROBLEM.
>> SO YOU WEREN'T LIKE THIS IS
FRAUD.
YOU'RE THINKING I'M JUST GOING
TO SOLVE THIS AND GET HIM HIS
MONEY.
>> I CALLED UP RICH AND SAID
THIS SHOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM.
IT'S PROBABLY A MISUNDERSTANDING
AT BEST.
RELAX, LET ME JUST SPEAK TO HIM
AND WE'LL WORK IT OUT.
WHEN I CALLED HIM, MY INTENTIONS
WERE JUST TO SETTLE THIS REALLY
QUICKLY AND MOVE ON.
BUT THE PROBLEM WAS IS THAT WHEN
I SPOKE TO HIM ON THE PHONE, HE
WAS NOT LISTENING TO WHAT I WAS
SAYING.
HE ALREADY MADE UP HIS MIND.
I SAID TO HIM, CAN YOU PLEASE
GIVE THE MONEY BACK TO THE
PEOPLE, OR THERE'S A
VETERINARIAN IN RICH'S AREA THAT
WE CAN GIVE THE MONEY TO AND PUT
IT INTO LIKE A FUND WHERE HE
COULD USE IT FROM TIME TO TIME.
IT'S NOT YOUR MONEY TO KEEP.
AND HE JUST WASN'T HEARING IT.
I CALLED RICH BACK HORRIFIED.
I WAS REALLY UPSET BECAUSE THIS
IS RICH'S LIFE LINE.
I WORK WITH VETERANS EVERY DAY.
AND DOGS SAVE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND HE NEEDED THIS DOG EVERY DAY
TO BE IN HIS LIFE.
AND I FELT HORRIBLE TO TELL HIM
THAT I FAILED HIM BECAUSE OF
FEELING THAT MR. -- AT THE TIME,
WAS GOING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND HE DID NOT.
>> AND YOU NEVER GOT A DOLLAR OF
THE MONEY?
>> NEVER GOT ANYTHING.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY SHE DIED?
>> SHE DIED ABOUT FOUR MONTHS
AFTER THIS ALL WENT DOWN.
THERE WAS A STRING OF TEXTS
BETWEEN ME AND HIM.
I TALKED TO HIM ONE TIME ON THE
PHONE.
IN ONE OF THE TEXTS I WAS SO
UPSET.
I KNEW I WASN'T GOING TO GET THE
MONEY AT THAT POINT.
I WAS, LIKE, I KNOW THAT YOU
MINED MY DOG AND MY FRIENDS AND
FAMILIES HEART TO RAISE MONEY
FOR YOURSELF.
HE TOLD ME THAT WAS THE MOST
OFFENSIVE HORRIBLE THING ANYBODY
HAD EVER SAID TO HIM.
THAT I THINK WAS THE BREAKING
POINT WHERE HE DECIDED HE WAS
NOT GOING TO GIVE ME THE MONEY.
HE WAS OFF THE HOOK, HE WANTED
TO CREATE A PROBLEM, A WEDGE
BETWEEN US.
>> AND THAT WAS IT.
SO CAN I ASK YOU NOW, THIS
HAPPENS IN YOUR LIFE.
THIS WAS YOUR LIFE LINE.
SHE IS GONE.
>> THAT DOG SAVED MY LIFE AT
LEAST TWO TIMES.
WHEN I FIRST GOT OUT OF THE
SERVICE I WAS DEPRESSED, I WAS
HAVING NIGHTMARES, BAD, BAD
MEMORIES ABOUT SOME THINGS THAT
HAPPENED.
NOT WAR RELATED BUT OTHER THINGS
THAT THE MILITARY DOES TO YOU.
I STARTED DRINKING TOO MUCH.
I WAS DOING RECKLESS STUFF.
MY FATHER EVEN TOLD ME HE
THOUGHT I HAD A DEATH WISH AT
THAT POINT.
AND I PROBABLY DID.
I WAS VERY SUICIDAL.
I WOULD START CRYING FOR NO
REASON.
IF I DIDN'T HAVE THAT LITTLE
PRINCESS WITH ME, I PROBABLY
WOULD'VE NOT BEEN HERE TO SPEAK
TO YOU RIGHT NOW, AT LEAST TWO
TIMES.
I WOULD THINK ABOUT HER, AND I
SAID NOBODY ELSE IS GOING TO BE
HER DADDY.
THAT'S MY DOG.
AND I'D CUDDLE WITH HER AND I'D
SNUGGLE UP WITH HER AND ALL THE
BAD STUFF WENT AWAY.
>> AND AT WHAT POINT DID YOU ALL
REALIZE THAT ANTHONY DUVOLDER IS
GEORGE SANTOS?
>> A WEEK AGO.
I STARTED SEEING HIS FACE ON
CABLE NEWS.
>> AND YOU'RE NOT FOLLOWING
POLITICS SO YOU KIND OF STUMBLED
ACROSS HIS FACE.
>> I WATCH THE NEWS ALL THE
TIME.
I LOVE MY YOUTUBE NEWS.
BUT I SAW HIS FACE AND I KNEW I
SORT OF RECOGNIZED HIM A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE WE HAD BEEN FACEBOOK
FRIENDS WHILE THE CAMPAIGN WAS
GOING ON.
SO I KNEW WHAT HE LOOKED LIKE.
AND I KNEW HIS VOICE.
THAT WAS THE ONLY THING I KNEW
ABOUT HIM.
I SAW HIM ON TV AND I WAS LIKE I
GOT A FEELING IN THE PIT OF MY
STOMACH ABOUT THIS GUY.
WHY DO I RECOGNIZE HIM?
AND THAT WAS IN DECEMBER RIGHT
AROUND CHRISTMASTIME.
JUST ABOUT A WEEK AGO, HE WAS IN
THE CAPITOL, AND THERE WAS A
BUNCH OF REPORTERS FOLLOWING HIM
AROUND ASKING QUESTIONS.
THAT'S ABOUT THE ONLY THING YOU
SEE OF HIM ANYMORE.
ONE OF THEM SAID WHAT'S YOUR
NAME TODAY, IS IT ANTHONY
DUVOLDER OR GEORGE SANTOS?
>> AH.
SO WHEN THAT NAME WAS SAID --
>> I WAS SICK.
TO SEE THAT SOMEBODY LIKE THAT
THAT COULD DO SOMETHING THAT
DASTARDLY COULD RAISE TO SUCH A
HIGH POSITION.
THAT SHOULDN'T BE RIGHT THAT.
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
>> LET ME ASK YOU.
DON LEMON REACHED OUT TO SANTOS,
TO GEORGE SANTOS, AND GOT HIM TO
RESPOND.
>> AND HE SAID I WAS FAKE.
YEAH, I READ THAT.
>> LET ME READ IT.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU EACH A CHANCE
TO RESPOND TO IT.
HE SAID, I HAVE NO CLUE WHAT
HE'S TALKING ABOUT, AND THE
CRAZY PART IS THAT ANYONE THAT
KNOWS ME KNOWS I'D GO TO HELL
AND BACK FOR A DOG AND
ESPECIALLY A VETERAN.
SO THIS IS JUST MORE OF THE
PILE-ON EFFECT.
I HAVE DOZENS OF PEOPLE REACHING
OUT TO ME IN SUPPORT, SHARING
THEIR STORIES ABOUT THEIR DOGS
AND CATS THAT I HELPED SAVE AND
RESCUE.
WHAT DO YOU EACH SAY TO THAT?
>> PROVE IT, SHOW US.
HE SHOULD SHOW US IF HE HAS ALL
THESE PEOPLE THAT REACH OUT TO
HIM AND LOVE WHAT HE DOES.
>> COMING HERE STAKING MY NAME
OF OUR CHARITY ON THIS.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THIS WAS
DONE AND IT'S HORRIBLE, THAT
THIS VETERAN HAS TO GO THIS.
WE LOSE 22 VETERANS A DAY AND
OUR CHARITY DOES WHATEVER WE CAN
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
AND WE RELY ON OTHER CHARITIES.
WHEN ANOTHER CHARITY CAUSES
PROBLEMS, IT CREATES PROBLEMS IN
HELPING THE LIVES OF OUR
VETERANS.
>> I KNOW IT'S HARD FOR YOU TO
TALK ABOUT THIS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR DOING IT.
AND OF COURSE, MICHAEL, YOU
COMING AS WELL.
>> TODAY HAS BEEN JUST A WHIRL
WIND OF PEOPLE CALLING ME AND
WANTING TO TALK.
I'M A VERY PRIVATE PERSON.
I HAD MY DOGS AND I REALLY NEVER
HAVE ANYBODY OVER TO MY HOUSE.
>> EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW YOU HA